D
THE LARGEST PROTESTANT
DENOMINATION IN THE UNITED
STATES EMBRACE CRITICAL RACE
THEORY?
SHOULD THEY ORDAIN FEMALE
MINISTERS?
THESE ARE SOME QUESTIONS THAT
ARE DIVIDING MORE THAN 14
MILLION MEMBERS OF THE SOUTHERN
FASTEST CONVENTION.
DELEGATES JUST ELECTING A NEW
PRESIDENT FOR THE MODERATE WING
OF THE CHURCH DEALING A MAJOR
BLOW TO OLDER CONSERVATIVES WHO
ARE PUSHING BACK ON WHAT THEY
CALL, QUOTE, WOKE IDEOLOGY.
NICK VALENCIA IS OUT FRONT.
>> IN NASHVILLE, THE MORNING
BEGAN THE SAME WAY IT OFTEN
DOES IN THOUSANDS IN
ATTENDANCE.
WORSHIP AND PRAISE FOR JESUS
BUT FOR SOME FIRST-TIME
ATTENDEES LIKE DEBBIE, THIS
YEAR'S SOUTHERN BAPTIST
CONVENTION IS A RECKONING FOR
CHRISTIANITY AND THE NATION.
>> THEY HAVE A PLACE IN
POLITICS?
>> YES.
>> PART OF THE FAR-RIGHT AND
MORE FUNDAMENTALIST CONTINGENT
OF SOUTHERN BAPTIST THAT WAS
JUST HANDED A BIG LOSS LAST
NIGHT WHEN MODERATE ED LATE WAS
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
SHE FEARS IT IS WHEN MEANS WOKE
IDEOLOGY LIKE TEACHING CRITICAL
RACE THEORY WILL TAKE HOLD IN
THE CHURCH AND SOCIETY.
THE ONLY WAY TO STOP IT, THE
FORMER TEACHER SAYS, IS FOR THE
SOUTHERN BAPTIST TO GET MORE
INVOLVED THAN EVER IN POLITICS.
>> WHEN YOU SAY SEPARATION OF
CHURCH AND STATE, YOU ARE
BASICALLY -- YOU ARE BASICALLY
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST A GROUP
OF PEOPLE.
>> AND IN THE SPIRIT OF TALKING
ABOUT DISCRIMINATION, DOES YOUR
STANCE AGAINST CRITICAL RACE
THEORY NOT RUN THE RISK OF
PUSHING OUT PEOPLE OF COLOR?
>> NO.
>> WHY NOT?
>> BECAUSE IN CHRIST, THERE IS
NO COLOR.
>> BUT LOOKING AROUND THE
CONVENTION GROUNDS, THE REALITY
IS VERY DIFFERENT.
35-YEAR-OLD ASSOCIATE PASTOR
ADAMS OF MONTGOMERY ALABAMA IS
ONE A FEW BLACK PEOPLE HERE.
ADAMS VOTED AS A MESSENGER FOR
THE FIRST TIME THIS YEAR.
HE HAS HOPE WHO IS POLITICALLY
CONSERVATIVE BUT IT CONSIDERED
A MODERATE BY SOME IN THE
DENOMINATION.
ISSUES LIKE CRITICAL RACE
THEORY AND THE BLACK LIVES
MATTER MOVEMENT.
>> THERE IS A REASON WHY
YOUNGER PEOPLE LIKE HIM, AND
THAT HAS TO DO WITH HIM BEING
FLEXIBLE AND UNDERSTANDABLE
TOWARDS DIFFERENT, LIKE SOME OF
THE NEWER ISSUES THAT HAVE COME
UP WITHIN THE SEC.
>> MORE PROGRESSIVE ISSUES?
>> EXACTLY.
>> SEX ABUSE SURVIVORS SAY HE
SHOULD FOCUS LESS ON POLITICS
AND INSTEAD ON WHAT THEY SAY IS
THE CHURCHES REAL PROBLEM.
IT'S MISHANDLING OF SEXUAL
ABUSE ALLEGATIONS.
A RECENT LETTER BETWEEN 2
HIGH-PROFILE SOUTHERN BAPTIST
LEADERS BROUGHT TO LIGHT NEW
ALLEGATIONS OF ALLEGED
SPIRITUAL AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
ABUSE OF SURVIVORS AS WELL AS
ATTEMPTS TO EXONERATE CHARGES
OF ABUSE CLAIMS.
AT A PRESS CONFERENCE AFTER
BEING ELECTED, LADEN CALLED
CHURCHES PLACES FOR PEOPLE TO
FEEL PROTECTED.
>> WE HAVE TO FIND A MECHANISM
AND A WAY TO HELP TRAIN OUR
PEOPLE, GET MORE CHURCHES
INVOLVED, AND WANTING TO CREATE
A SAFE ENVIRONMENT IN THEIR
CHURCH AND TO MEET KNOWN AS
GREAT PEOPLE.
>> BUT THEY SAY SOME IN THE
DENOMINATION EVEN ONE OF HER
BEST FRIENDS HAVE TURNED THEIR
BACK ON HER FOR SPEAKING OUT.
SHE SAYS OTHERS HAVE ENCOURAGED
HER POINT BLANK TO BE QUIET
ABOUT HER ABUSE.
>> THE CHURCH NEEDS A DAY OF
RECKONING.
IT NEEDS TO BE A STRIPPING DOWN
TO THE BASES, BASICS OF
EVERYTHING THAT YOU SAY YOU
STAND FOR.
EVERYTHING YOU CLAIM TO
REPRESENT, YOUR VIEW, THE WORLD,
THE GRID COMMISSION BAPTIST.
HOW DOES THE WORLD REALLY SEE
YOU?
DO THEY SEE U.S. HYPOCRITES?
?
DO THE
>> THE PATH AHEAD FOR THEM IS
CLEAR FOR SOME.
THAT PATH MAY NOT BE FOR ALL.
THEY ARE JUGGLING HOW TO HANDLE
MORE PROGRESSIVE ISSUES LIKE
CRITICAL RACE THEORY, THE BLACK
LIVES MATTER MOVEMENT, WHILE
NOT STRAYING TOO FAR FROM ITS
FOUNDATION.
WHAT IS CLEAR IS A NEWLY
ELECTED PRESIDENT ED LITTON WE
WILL HEAR FROM SHORTLY WILL
HAVE TO HANDLE THE ISSUES THAT
ARE AT THE CENTER OF THE
NATION'S POLITICAL DEBATE.
THINGS LIKE RACE, GENDER, AND
EQUALITY.
>> CERTAINLY EVANGELICAL FAITH
AND BAPTIST IS THE CENTER OF
ALL OF THESE ISSUES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND I WANT TO GO OUT FRONT TO
PASTOR ED LITTON WHO WON THAT
ELECTION FOR PRESIDENT OF THE
SOUTHERN BAPTIST CONVENTION.
PASTOR, I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU FOR SPEAKING OUT.
YOU ARE FACING A CULTURAL
DIVIDE.
PEOPLE ARE AROUND THIS COUNTRY.
AND IN YOUR CHURCH AS WELL.
ESPECIALLY ON THE ISSUE OF
CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
IT RECOGNIZES SYSTEMIC RACISM
IS PART OF AMERICAN SOCIETY
THAT CHALLENGES LAW AND PROMOTE
INEQUALITY.
BUT CONSERVATIVES SOUTHERN
BAPTIST PASTOR MIKE STONE SAYS
OUR LORD ISN'T WOKE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THOSE IN
YOUR OWN CONVENTION WHO BELIEVE
THE CHARGES DRIFTING TOO FAR TO
THE LEFT?
>> THERE IS NO MODERATE WAY TO
THE MOTORIST CONVENTION.
I'M NOT A MODERATE BY ANY
THEOLOGICAL DEFINITION.
I'M VERY CONSERVATIVE IN MY
FACE, THEOLOGY.
AS YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR PIECE,
IN MY POLITICS.
WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS
FOR THE GOSPEL AND ANOTHER LOVE
OF JESUS CHRIST.
THIS IS NOT A LEFTWARD DRIFT AT
ALL AND IT'S NOT A GOOD
CHARACTERIZATION BECAUSE THERE
ARE NO MODERATES IN SOUTHERN
BAPTIST LIFE.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT, BUT THE
CRITICISM NONETHELESS COMES TO
YOU FROM ANOTHER PASTOR.
OUR LORD ISN'T WOKE.
ANGRY THAT YOU ARE RECOGNIZING
AS A GROUP CRITICAL RACE
THEORY.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?D AS A
>> I CAN EXPLAIN SIMPLY.
WE'VE NEVER CONDONE CRITICAL
RACE THEORY.
THIS CONVENTION, WE HAVE BEEN
VERY CLEAR, REPEATEDLY, THAT IT
IS A PHILOSOPHY, IT'S A WORLD
VIEW, IT'S A WAY OF SEEING
THINGS IN THE CULTURE WE LIVE,
AND BUT WE DO NOT ADOPT IT.
WE MAY TEACH IT TO HELP PASTORS
UNDERSTAND IT'S A MECHANISM
USED IN OUR CULTURE AND WE HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND IT.
>> YOU ARE SAYING YOU DO NOT
RECOGNIZE -- ADOPTING THE
THEORY, THAT RECOGNIZES
SYSTEMIC RACISM IS A PART OF
AMERICAN SOCIETY.
YOU ARE SAYING THAT'S NOT TRUE?
>> I DIDN'T SAY THERE ISN'T
SYSTEMIC RACISM.
THAT'S OBVIOUS.
I'M SAYING WE DO NOT PRESCRIBE
TO CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
THAT'S WHAT WAS PART OF WHAT
YOU SAID.
WE DO NOT PRESCRIBE TO IT.
THAT'S A FALSE NARRATIVE.
WE BELIEVE IN GOSPEL, WE
BELIEVE IN GOSPEL
RECONCILIATION.
ONE OF THE --
>> MAYBE WE ARE JUST
MISUNDERSTANDING EACH OTHER, I
DO WANT TO TRY AND UNDERSTAND.
AS I THINK IT IS SO CRUCIAL.
YOU ARE SAYING THERE IS
SYSTEMIC RACISM, BUT THERE ARE
SOME WHO SAY EVEN IN YOUR OWN
FAITH GROUPS, THAT QUOTE OUR
LORD ISN'T WOKE.
THEY'RE FRUSTRATED HE WOULD
EVEN DO THAT.
HOW DO YOU HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WHEN YOU FEEL
DIFFERENTLY ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT IS SO CRUCIAL AND CORE
RIGHT NOW TO WHAT THIS COUNTRY
IS GOING THROUGH?
>> IT IS CRUCIAL TO WHAT OUR
COUNTRY IS GOING THROUGH.
THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION IS
JESUS TELLS US TO.. -- THE WORD
OF GOD TELLS YOU TO RESUME
TOGETHER.
OUR DESIRE IS WE COME TO OUR
CONVENTION, WE GATHER, WE
REAFFIRM OUR STATEMENTS, AND
NOTHING CHANGED IN ANY OF OUR
DOCTRINE AL STATEMENTS IN THIS
CONVENTION, AND THEY WON'T.
WE REAFFIRM WHO WE ARE, WHAT'S
OUR MISSION IS AS A CONVENTION
OF ALMOST 50,000 CHURCHES.
WE REAFFIRM THOSE THINGS.
BUT WE NEED A BETTER
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS BECAUSE
THESE ALLEGATIONS ARE FALSE.
WE ARE NOT -- LET ME TELL YOU
WHY I THINK THIS IS HAPPENING.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE AFRAID
THE OF DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE.
IT'S BASICALLY RECOGNIZING
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE CREATING THE
IMAGE OF GOD, HAVE VALUED
BECAUSE GOD LOVES THEM AND
REDEEMS THEM, AND GOD WANTS
THEM AND IN HIS FAMILY.
IT'S OUR MISSION TO HELP GET
THAT GOSPEL MESSAGE TO
EVERYBODY.
>> LET ME ASK YOU ANOTHER
THING.
I KNOW THIS, THERE'S A RECENT
POLL, I'M SURE YOU ARE AWARE OF
THIS, PASTOR, THAT SHOWS 25% OF
WHITE EVANGELICALS BELIEVE IN
THE QANON CONSPIRACY THEORY.
I SPOKE TO A REVEREND RECENTLY,
SO YOU KNOW, HE SAID HE WAS
SPEAKING TO PASTORS FROM EVERY
DENOMINATION.
HE TOLD ME SAYING LITERALLY
EVERY SINGLE DAY, AND THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT THIS PROBLEM.
SOME PASTORS ARE PROMOTING THE
SENTIMENT BEHIND THIS THEORY
AND THEIR SERMONS, OTHERS ARE
TRYING TO COMBAT IT.
I WANT TO PLAY SOME OF THE
POSTURES THAT ARE PUTTING THIS
TO THEIR FLOCKS ALONG WITH
FORMER CHRISTIAN QANON
BELIEVERS.
THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE GOING TO
HEAR.
>> THERE IS A DEMONIC
PROTECTION AROUND JOE BIDEN.
>> JOE BIDEN IS A FAKE
PRESIDENT!
>> WE HAVE MANY PEOPLE IN OUR
GOVERNMENT THAT ARE VERY
COMPROMISED.
AND THERE IS A PLAN THAT IS
TRYING TO TURN THAT OVER TO GET
THEM AND PUT THESE PEOPLE
BEHIND BARS.
OKAY?
>> EVEN THE GROUP, I WAS LIKE,
I'M GOING TO THESE MORE THAN I
GO TO CHURCH ONCE A WEEK.
I'M UP HERE FOR 2 HOURS EVERY
SINGLE NIGHT, LIKE COMMITTED TO
THESE.
THAT WAS LIKE, THAT'S PROBABLY
NOT RIGHT, AND I STARTED
THINKING, AM I PUTTING EVEN
TRUMP OF GOD?
I AM >> CNN ALSO SPOKE TO A
RETIRED SOUTHERN BAPTIST PASTOR,
PARKER IN MISSISSIPPI.
HE SAID HE BELIEVED QANON.
HIS COMMENT WAS, QUOTE, IT
SEEMED TO BE GOOD SOLID
CONSERVATIVE THOUGHT.
PASTOR, HAVE YOU ENCOUNTERED
THIS?
WHAT CAN BE DONE ABOUT THIS?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I HAVE NOT
ENCOUNTERED IT IN MY CHURCH.
I DON'T KNOW MANY PASTORS WHO
HAVE.
I THINK IT'S A FRINGE PROBLEM.
SO ALMOST 50,000 SOUTHERN
CHURCHES MOST PASTURES ARE
DOING THIS FAITHFULLY TEACHING
GOD'S WORD EVERY WEEK.
THE OPEN THE BIBLE, THEY BRING
MESSAGES OF LIFE TO PEOPLE,
HOPE TO PEOPLE, AND CONSPIRACY
THEORIES ARE ALL ACROSS OUR
CULTURE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S SOME
CHURCHES DOING.
THIS I THINK THERE'S ALL KINDS
OF BRANCH ELEMENTS THAT WILL
BELIEVE A LIGHT RATHER THAN THE
TRUTH.
>> THAT MAY BE TRUE.
I GUESS YOU'RE TAKING ISSUE THE
POLAR 25%?
ANOTHER PASTOR THOUGHT IT WAS
10%, MOST OF THE CONGREGATION
SEE NEW.
THE QUESTION I WOULD ASK YOU,
DO YOU FEEL ANY BURDEN,
OBLIGATION, RESPONSIBILITY TO
TRY TO STOP THIS?
WHETHER YOU'D FIND IT AS FRINGE
OR NOT?
>> IT IS FRENCH, BUT I HAVE AN
OBLIGATION WITH MY PEOPLE,
ESPECIALLY THAT I'D HE
GENERALLY LURE BASIS TO NOT
LISTEN TO FABLES AND THE
SCRIPTURE IS CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
SO, TO BUILD YOUR LIFE ON THE
WORD OF GOD, THAT'S THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR LIVES.
SO, THE BIBLE IS VERY REAL, AND
IT DEALS WITH REAL LIFE ISSUES.
SO THERE ARE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, AND THERE ARE PEOPLE
THAT FOLLOW THOSE THINGS.
BUT OUR PEOPLE, AND I THINK OUR